rihanna gives off casual chic in a new
maternity look as she was spotted out
and about in new york city on thursday
the mom-to-be wore an oversized leopard
print coat that exposed her growing baby
bump she paired the look with sweatpants
and a detroit tiger's hat accessorizing
with a long gold chain over her belly
earrings and an ankle bracelet whatever
i do it's gonna be confident it's no
surprise that the 33 year old has been
slaying her maternity looks
recently she opened up to e.t about
style and pregnancy at an immersive
beauty event honoring her fenty beauty
and fancy skin lines you know redefining
what it means to even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend
as rihanna prepares for motherhood her
best project yet a source tells e.t that
she and boyfriend rapper asap rocky will
be quote very hands-on parents i'm just
excited for what i don't know yet you
know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited the source says
quote while rihanna and asap rocky may
be one of the most successful celeb
couples when it comes down to their
private life they're actually pretty
humble i know thank you so much it's no
question that this baby can have
anything in the world but the source
adds quote more than anything this baby
will be spoiled with love and attention
i'm looking forward to it you know also
with ties to new york los angeles and
barbados the source says this baby is
going to be well traveled while la will
be the home base for their family
they'll likely spend time in the
hamptons this summer and rihanna's home
country of barbados will be one of their
first trips with the baby
it's all an exciting journey so far as
far as seeing riri out and about after
she gives birth the source shares that
in the early days with a baby we can
expect the beauty mogul to keep a low
profile
of course with the baby on the way fans
are eager to know if we can expect new
music anytime soon
well here's what rihanna tells e.t well
let's talk about this other baby that we
all want to know about
when is this maybe do you think this
stage in your life is going to inspire
new music
oh gosh
you can't ever you know this one my fans
love you you know
because you asked all the good questions
uh well
yes you're still gonna get music from me
maybe a lullaby i could see you and asap
dropping demos in the studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby letting us sleep with this
music they're like we are grown yeah
[Music]
you